it's day 31 of the partial shutdown and
president Trump is blasting Democrats
for rejecting his proposal to reopen the
government the president offering up
protections for daca recipients in
exchange for border wall funding but
Democrats are refusing to budge Senator
Chuck Schumer ramping up the rhetoric
while slamming Trump's compromise if he
opens up the government will discuss
whatever he offers but hostage taking
should not work the American people are
overwhelmingly against it
the president's poll ratings are
plummeting because even his own
supporters agree that this is a bad
tactic and it's very hard to negotiate
when a gun is held to your head
Republicans could be ready to force the
hand of Democrats Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell says he's going to bring
up Trump's plan for a vote this week and
just a moment ago well 13 minutes ago
actually president Trump tweeted about
the wall again and he said this if Nancy
Pelosi thinks that walls are immoral
why isn't she requesting that we take
down all the existing walls which
between the u.s. and Mexico even the new
ones just built in San Diego at their
very strong urging let millions of
unchecked strangers just flow into the
United States and that actually was a
question that I wanted to ask Gregg
which is the Democrats have said that
the wall is a moral yes so if you go if
you're there how do you then negotiate
since we talked to do it like a border
secure I said this last week I said how
do you good boy I wanted to bring it how
do you I said that they should actually
remove the walls between Mexico and
America and it's a I think I said this
last week by the way is it a moral or
immoral well I think well you tell me
you're the editor it's immoral here's
okay so here's we have a problem here
the more Trump negotiates with practical
compromises the more infantile and
personal that Democrats seem to be
taking this but it shows the problem
they started at the wrong end
you should always begin with a
multi-faceted approach the problem the
the prison of two ideas we keep saying
you could only have one position right
you're either for immigration or against
immigration and that is baloney you can
have a number of different positions on
immigration for example my I'm Pro
immigration and I'm Pro refugee with
extreme vetting I don't see how you I
think you know refugees
make great citizens because they're
grateful but you gotta get extreme
vetting because you never know if
there's gonna be terrorists coming in
there will skittle metaphor but that is
that is a that's out I'm living outside
of this prison of two ideas and words
now stuck in this thing where you have
to be this or this and it's it's it's
killing the debate the other rhetorical
xsi I noticed this weekend is the
Democrats saying that the president is
taking hostages and again I guess the
sake of WoW are we really talking about
that I mean when we're talking about
border security the president has come
off as position of like a whole wall
across the whole thing like like that
but hostage taking that takes it to a
new extreme hard to negotiate with that
Schumer said that will reopen the
government and we can't even discuss
border security until you do that well
the president offered Nancy Pelosi that
he said you know what if we reopen the
government can we do a deal on a barrier
later on and you know what she said no
and then he said Bob I and that was the
time he walked out of the room Greg
brings up the point if you say you're
for the wall the Democrats have to say
we're against the wall thus every
reporter should be asking that very
question
congresswoman senator do you believe
that we should tear down the existing
wall zone since they are immoral and
since they obviously don't work you
would have the government reopened right
now if we had a fair media in this
country because they would be asking
these logical questions to Democrats and
not protecting the Democratic position
and the intensity would be so strong on
Nancy she would have to come to the
negotiating table so far I believe she's
lost this argument if you look at her
getting grounded on the flight if you
look at the Puerto Rican PR disaster
Trump is moderating his position these
logical arguments they just can't argue
with all they say is oh it's mean so if
you look at what he's offering he's
offering humanitarian assistance he's
offering changes to the asylum he says
only 280 additional walls to be needed
and to be built and what are they saying
no and millions of people are still not
getting paid I don't think that's very
compassionate one the Democrats don't
seem to
things that they're losing they're not
losing I mean it's you know Jessie if
this was about the meeting I think it's
about the media I think it's about the
president and his stand and what he
considers to be a political symbol that
he can't afford to lose not they would
have gone back and said he waited mr.
president I thought Mitch McConnell the
Republicans in the Senate joined and
saying let's keep the government open
let's keep people getting paid let's
keep our economy growing and then let's
negotiate initially what did the
president say and then he said no
because of pressure from the right wing
talk show host or maybe the media if
they were fear would say mr. president
you had a Republican majority for two
years in the house in the Senate didn't
seem to be a priority did it but here's
the thing he now goes after Nancy Pelosi
as radical radical what's radical here
is the president has a weak negotiating
hand and I think it's starting to show I
think people were disappointed what came
Saturday everybody thought there's gonna
be a big announcement he's gonna do
something big on Saturday afternoon you
didn't like my god this is exactly what
you would want no absolutely not
he said listen let me just say remember
great Mackesy Jesse was saying to me
last week a one if it's so easy why
don't you tell me what you want well
guess what the president now is talking
about well we could have more technology
we could have more border agents we
could have more judges he sounds like
he's starting to negotiate on the
Democrats terms but he doesn't he
doesn't say I'm going to stop this I'm
going to stop this shutdown he basically
said he originally he was just talking
about a wall and I said that was a
mistake because he was only focused on
the wall that was the campaign promise
but he had to talk about other things
now he comes to the table and he says
all right we need these barriers but I'm
also gonna provide the humanitarian aid
I'm also going to provide the wall not
to say that he lost
he would have to say okay I'm not
interested in the steel barriers at the
Border Patrol agents have asked where he
would have to remove the component
that's the wall in order for the
Democrats to get on board that's because
they want to deny him that talking point
so that he made a campaign promise and
if he includes that border security
measure in there it's a campaign about
let me say the privacy made was Mexico
will pay I don't see that at all about
that little point that would have been a
better one